un sociólogo que estudia fertilidad en
francia y suiza quería probar si existe
alguna diferencia en el número promedio
de bebés que tienen las mujeres en cada
país
el sociólogo obtuvo una muestra
aleatoria de mujeres de cada país aquí
están los resultados de la prueba
podemos ver una muestra de 100 personas
en francia una muestra de 100 personas
en suiza- en realidad las muestras no
tienen que ser del mismo tamaño tenemos
nuestras medias de muestra nuestras
desviaciones estándar de muestra tenemos
el error estándar de la media que para
cada muestra sería la estimación de la
desviación estándar de la distribución
muestral de medias y aquí indica que la
prueba t para las medias de estas
diferentes poblaciones son diferentes y
sólo para asegurarnos de que podemos
darle sentido a esto recordemos lo que
está sucediendo en la hipótesis nula
estipula que no hay diferencia en el
número promedio de bebés que tienen las
mujeres en francia- en comparación con
el número promedio de bebés que tienen
las mujeres en suiza- esa sería nuestra
hipótesis nula la hipótesis de que no
cambia y nuestra alternativa sería que
son diferentes y eso es lo que tenemos
justo aquí es una prueba t para ver si
tenemos evidencia que sugiera nuestro
hipótesis alternativa y entonces lo que
hacemos es suponer la hipótesis nula a
partir de eso podemos calcular un
estadístico t y luego a partir de ese
estadístico t con sus grados de libertad
podemos calcular un valor p y si ese
valor p está por debajo de nuestro nivel
de significancia entonces iremos oye
este era un escenario bastante
improbable vamos a rechazar la hipótesis
nula lo que sugeriría la alternativa
pero si el valor p es mayor que nuestro
nivel de significancia no podremos
rechazar la hipótesis nula y por lo
tanto no tendremos evidencia suficiente
para concluir la alternativa entonces
qué está pasando aquí realmente solo
tenemos que comparar este valor con este
valor dice que al nivel de significancia
de alfa igual a 0.05 hay evidencia
suficiente para concluir que existe una
diferencia en el número promedio de
bebés que tiene las mujeres en cada país
bueno podemos ver que nuestro valor p
0.13 es mayor que nuestro valor alfa
0.05 y por eso no podemos rechazar
nuestra hipótesis nula y para responder
a la pregunta no no hay evidencia
suficiente para
concluir que hay una diferencia no hay
evidencia suficiente para rechazar la
hipótesis nula y sugerir la alternativa